okay everybody
let's begin
um welcome back
good to see you all here on zoom
um
so we're going to pick up with what we
had been discussing
um
last week
which was
um
a
an introduction to
np completeness so we're following on
our
description of
time complexity
we we started talking about the time
complexity classes
the class p
the non-deterministic classes the class
np p versus np problem and then leading
to this discussion of np completeness
and today we're going to prove the big
theorem in the field uh which really
kind of got things going uh back in the
early 1970s by cook and levin that uh
there was actually an mp complete
problem called that sat in particular is
an np complete problem and then we'll
also talk about threesat which is a
useful tool
um
so just to remember just to uh remember
we had this notion of np completeness
for
languages that be complete if it's in np
and everything else in np is polynomial
time reducible to it
and if an np complete problem
turns out to have a polynomial time
solution then every np problem has a
polynomial time solution
and that's part of the importance of np
completeness uh because since we
uh consider it unlikely that p equals np
uh
and that there probably are some
problems
that uh are in np but are not solvable
in polynomial time
that's
would me imply that an np-complete
problem would have that property and so
proving
a problem and being mp complete is
evidence very strong evidence that it
doesn't have a polynomial time uh
solution and so therefore it's we call
intractable uh it's a very difficult
problem
um
so um
the way we are going to typically show
problems np-complete is by reducing a
known a previously known np-complete
problem to that problem
often it's three-sat
as we've seen several examples already
or it could be some other uh example so
let's just survey briefly uh the things
that we've already
languages that we've already seen
which are mp complete
so we have the languages sat which is a
direct reduction from every np problem
and
so we're going to show that today
that every np language is polynomial
time reducible to sat which is in turn
reducible to three sat
and
we showed previously
that threesat is reducible to clique and
hampf
and
in recitation if you went to that they
showed that the subset sub problem and
the undirected hand path problems are
also
reducible from previously uh shown well
from uh from either from 3sat
or in the case of their undirected hand
path problem it's reducible from the
hand path problem
and the conclusion once we have
these two blue
reducibilities shown
then we know that all of these problems
are np-complete
um
so the class np basically breaks down
into the np complete problems
p problems problems that are in p and
then there might be problems in between
as well so there are some problems that
are not known to be in either category
and in fact there's a old theorem which
shows that if p is different from np
then there are actually problems that
are in the intermediate state
and um
of course
it's possible that p equals np
and then everything collapses down uh to
be the same with the tiny exception of
the um sigma star and empty set
languages which can never be uh complete
um
okay um so that's our quick review
here's a check in that i'm gonna use to
get us ready for the
big proof that we're gonna be spending
most of the lecture on about um
uh showing sat as np-complete but just
to define a little notation which you
might have maybe you've seen already um
but i'm going to do it in the form of a
check-in
so
i'm sure you've all seen the big sum
notation uh using a sigma
to represent a sum over um
over some set of possibilities
just as there is the big sigma notation
we have you can have other operations um
that apply to a a set of uh elements so
in this case we're going to be seeing
the big and and the big or
operation uh it's going to a notation
which is going to allow us to talk about
taking the end of many things or the ore
of many things um because we're we're
going to be building these boolean
formulas and so ands and orders are
going to be the uh operations that we're
going to be focusing on
and so just as an example just to
make sure you're we're all understanding
this notation if you have
uh two strings x and y
uh written out in terms of their
individual symbols so they're both of
length n so x is x1 to xn
y is y 1 to y n
and
now i write the following expression the
big and
for i ranging between 1 and n
of x i equal to y i if that big and is
true what does it tell us about x and y
and i'm just going to offer you two
possibilities that either x and y agree
in some symbol
or they are equal namely that they agree
on every symbol
and so
let's just pull that up as a
quick poll to get us going here
um
[Music]
i just want to make sure you understand
the notation because we're going to be
using that a lot
in describing the uh
polynomial time reduction
from
uh
languages in np to the sat language
okay i think most of you have got the
idea but
so let's finish this up quick
um
see another 15 seconds please
just to give you a chance to participate
um
okay so i'm gonna close this uh
close this poll
last chance let's call
all right
so yes
the big and
as most of you
can see the big and says that you know
x1 equals y1 and x2 equals y2 and x3
equals y3 so they're all
um
every symbol in x is equal to the
corresponding symbol in y
if we had a big or instead of a big and
the uh then a would be the correct
answer because then just there would be
some place where they agree instead of
every place where they they agree
um
okay
so let's um
then
start
to launch in to this big theorem
the proof itself
is a massive details
um with one underlying idea
and in fact it's an idea we've seen
before um but let's before we get ahead
of ourselves let's just understand what
we're trying to do
uh
so we want to show that this language
sat is np-complete remember what's that
is it's boolean formulas that are
satisfiable
uh
so we already showed that the set pro so
being mp complete means it has these two
features it's in np
and everything in np is reducible to it
so first of all sat is np as we've
already seen
the witness that shows a formula is
satisfiable is simply the satisfying
assignment that evaluates the true
so now we're going to pick
some language in np a
and show that a is polynomial time
reducible to
okay
so this is going to apply to any
language a and np so let a be some
language in np
it's decided by some non-deterministic
turing machine m in time into the k
that's what it means to be an np um i'm
going to make ignoring the constant
factors when we could carry that
throughout the proof it just would make
this the the description a little more
cumbersome and wouldn't change any of
the ideas but so let's just say it's
m runs in time into the k
and
recognizes or decides this language a in
uh
uh so it's an it's
in and it's a non-deterministic machine
so we've got to give a polynomial time
reduction from a to sad that's that's
what i have to
demonstrate to you
so what does that reduction look like
it's going to map strings
which may or may not be an a
to formulas which may or may not be
satisfied
that's what the reduction's got to do
so
saying
saying that out
more formally is
it's going to take some string w and map
it to a formula we'll call f sub m w
where m is the
machine that
um
decides a and w is is is the input
so f is going to map w to this formula
where the string is in the language
exactly when the formula is satisfiable
and the formula is going to depend upon
m and w that's why it just has it's
written in this way so we've seen that
kind of thing before
so basically my
my job
you know you know we have this language
a that's an np and now we have some
string w which might be an a or maybe
not is an a
and i have to
quickly in polynomial time now produce a
formula
which is going to be satisfiable exactly
when
the string w is in a
okay so how is that formula going to
work
how can i produce such a formula which i
mean i of course i don't know whether w
is in a or not um because i i'm just a
polynomial time reduction
and um a is an np language so
polynomial time probably is not enough
to solve whether w is in a so i've got
to make matt do that mapping without
knowing
the answer
and the idea is that um and this is
where you know we've seen things like
this before
the formula we're going to construct
simulates the machine on w
so in some way it's going to do that
simulation the trick is figuring out how
to what that means
um but
the the interpretation of that formula
is that in a sense describes and it says
though in my informal language that m
accepts w
very much like
you know
there's a lot of parallel here between
um
this construction and for example the
construction um the pcp construction
where we
made a an instant you know
given a machine and an
input we made a set of those dominoes
where finding a match forced you to
simulate the machine
here finding a satisfying assignment
is going to force you to simulate the
machine
[Music]
so this satisfying assignment is going
to be a computation history for mmw
and i'm just going to write that
computation history in a particular way
so it's going to have a somewhat
different encoding which is going to
help us to visualize what's going on
better
okay
um
so that's that's the
that's the
that's the approach that's the basic
idea of what we're trying to what we're
gonna do so i'm happy to take a minute
if that's
if you have any questions about this
part but um
otherwise i'll just move on to start
doing the actual construction of what
the formula looks like how is it going
to do that how is that formula going to
work
okay so no questions hopefully
we are uh all together
okay
so
first of all
let me describe what my computation
histories are going to look like
and and the situation is a little bit
different than what we had before
because
um when we were talking about the post
correspondence problem we had a
deterministic machine and now our
machine is
non-deterministic
okay so
um
we're going to call the object instead
of an accepting computation or
computation history we're just going to
we're going to call it a tableau or
sometimes an accepting tableau if you
want to
emphasize the accepting nature of it but
generally we're just going to call it a
tableau
so a tableau
is really an accepting computation
history
for
um for
for the machine
on an accepting branch
of its non-deterministic computation
so if m accepts w
it's got to have some accepting branch
and the
tableau
is going to be the sequence of
configurations that the machine goes
through on that accepting branch if
there are several accepting branches
there may be several tableaus there will
there will be several tableaus so
there's going to be one tableau for each
accepting branch of the
of the machine's computation on w
if the machine does not accept w there
won't be any tableaus
and so the whole point is that we're
going to make our formula
and
represent
the statement
that there is a tableau
and satisfying that formula is going to
correspond to filling out
the symbols in in the tableau to make it
a tableau
okay so here is a tableau um so
tableau is just again an accepting
computation history on some branch some
accepting branch of the machine's
computation
so and and it the rows of the ins
instead of writing the
computation history out linearly we're
going to represent it
in a table form where each configuration
is going to be on a separate row
all right
now the dimensions of that table are
going to be n to the k by n to the k
because the
machine
runs for n to the k steps
so
there's gonna if there's an accepting
branch it's going to accept within that
number of steps and we'll have enough
rows here to write down all of the
configurations that the machine goes
through one after the next row by row
each one having a configuration
uh in it
and uh
and then at the bottom there'll be an
accept
you know minor detail if the machine
accepts earlier we'll just say the
machine stays in the set once it's
it enters an accept
the machine does not change
from that point on so the rule of the
machine is
nothing changes and it just remains in
the same configuration from that point
on
okay um
so
um
important to understand what we're you
know if you're if you're not following
what i mean by a tableau
you're doomed
for this lecture
so
it it makes sense if you know for you to
ask a question
to understand what we mean by tableau
okay so just a few more elements here so
this is going to be the start
configuration for mw this would be an
accepting configuration here down at the
very last row
um
and you might imagine you know i i
think i filled out some
hypothetical
first step of the machine after the
start
where
maybe the machine was
a when it's in remember how we can
encode our configurations so this is the
machine is in state q0 looking at w uh
the first symbol of the input w1 and
maybe when it's
in q0 or looking in that first symbol
it moves to state q 7
and goes right
and then changes that w 1 to an a
and so now here is the head shown moved
1 position to the right in the new state
q7
i mean of course that depends on what
the machine is designed to do what the
what the transition function is but this
um
you know could possibly is
what happens so does the
okay so good does a tableau trace all
steps of all branches
no
the tableau corresponds to one accepting
branch
each different accepting branch is going
to have its own tableau so there might
be several different ways of filling out
that second row even of course the first
row is going to be in any tableau it's
got to be the same
um
you know
once i know w
here i've written down maybe i should
unpack this for you you know it's in the
start state here then here are the first
you know here are the n symbols of w w
is of length n so it's w 1 w 2 up to w n
and then i'm padding out the rest with
blanks
so i should have said that too but okay
um
so i want to make my table into the k by
n to the k because that's going to be
enough
to represent the entire
uh
um all of these
configurations
of m
uh running for most into the k steps
right because the machine
um even if it sends its head
moving to the right as fast as it
possibly can
it's never going to have um it's it's
never going to
go outside this box
if it only runs for n to the k steps so
this is going to be big enough to
represent the entire computation of
m assuming it's running for n to the k
time and
the input w is of like that
all right um
what is k so k is the running time of
the machine so we assumed from the
previous slide that m runs in time n to
the k
okay um
so a good question here how can the
tableau be a square table if we have a
low number of computation histories but
a lot of tape um
well i mean the low number of
computation history that that's a
problem you're not saying that well you
know there
each computation history
is in a different table
so this i'm representing a single
computation history here there may be
there are going to be many
configurations
um so i can't have a small number of
configurations using a lot of tape
because
you know i can only use one more cell in
one more one additional tape cell each
time i meant you know if each additional
step of the machine
is yes so there's really no difference
between this if you want to think of
this as a computation history that's
fine this is really just the standard
terminology that's used when you're
proving um
this this particular theorem typically
people talk about it as a tableau but
it's really just the computation history
um
the cue state i mean
the question about the what are these
states queue this is the way we
represent configurations
so this means the machine is in
uh state
they're not all going down the diagonal
the the states are going to zigzag here
through he through this picture here
depending upon how the head of the
machine moves
so you have to go back and review how we
represented configurations of the
machine remember the configuration is a
snapshot
of the machine at a given point
um
how do we know that m runs in polynomial
time we're assuming m runs in polynomial
we started off with a language that's in
np
so it's it's a non-deterministic
polynomial time machine and we're
picking one branch
that accepts
and writing down all the sequence
configurations the machine goes through
let's move on and maybe as
you know ask more questions as they come
to you and i'll pick out some to answer
if that's going to be helpful to others
um
okay
um
so uh
we're going to now construct
this
um
uh
formula
to say that m accepts w again that was
what we uh that's our goal
and it says that a tableau for m on w
exists
um
and basically what that means is we want
to say that it starts right
it ends right and everything in between
is right
and then we're going to need some other
stuff to talk about how we're going to
be encoding those symbols using boolean
variables
so those are going to be the four parts
here's the start starts right here it
ends right here it moves right and here
it talks about the encoding of the
symbols into boolean variables
so those are the four parts of this
formula that i'm going to describe
um
i hope you got your question
answered as to why the total number of
columns is into the k because it's just
big enough to fit the entire all
configurations if the is running for at
most end of the case steps
which is what we're assuming
okay
okay so now
just
getting back to that i'm going to
describe these different components now
on separate slots
um
let me start off with with this
component fee cell which
is sort of the most fundamental one
because it talks about how we're going
to be encoding
those symbols of the tableau
into the boolean variables
so again here's kind of our the picture
to have in mind uh of this tableau this
is this into the k by enter the k table
representing
um you know the some
accepting branch
of the machine's computation
if there is one
and so now
let me draw a
some one of the cells here i'm going to
magnify it
so this is the i
j cell
here
and le i'm going to there there are
going to be
a collection of boolean variables
associated with each one of the cells so
each one of the cells is going to have a
bunch of variables all to itself
and those are going to be basically
indicator variables they're going to
indicate
which symbol that cell gets to uh have
in it
okay so again picture here
um
the in this tableau
you know we don't know how it's going to
get filled out but however it gets
filled out each one of these cells
gets some symbol
um
and that symbol could either be a tape
alphabet symbol or it's symbol
representing a state
right that's the way we do our
configurations
so it could be a tape alphabet symbol
here
showing the magnification
maybe it's the tape alphabet symbol
which represents the blank symbol
or maybe it's a
represents some state
okay
now how am i going to encode that with
variables
so
this let me this is the collection of
variables that's going to apply to the
entire formula fees of mw
um
each cell is so each cell ij is going to
have um
a set of variables
one for each possible
symbol sigma
that's
um in the configuration alphabet namely
a tape symbol
or a state symbol
okay
um
[Music]
so i'm gonna have
well maybe this will become clear as i'm
writing it so
if i turn the the
uh the variable x i j sigma
equal to true
that's just a way of saying that cell i
j contains a sigma so if i have x
you know i j
a
that means the symbol contains an a so
i'm going to illustrate that now for you
so imagine you have lights representing
all the different
x i js
x i js for the different sigmas
i didn't say that well so
um
we're in cell i j so these are all x i j
variables they're x all x i j sigma
variables for the different sigmas
that can go in that can go in this uh
cell
so all different possible sigmas so this
is
gamma union q
okay so
now
um
if i have an a here
in that cell
so then the variable extra
a
is true
and i'm just helping you visualize that
i'm going to that's going to correspond
to turning the light on there's going to
be a light associated with each one of
these variables and it's be turned on
when that variable is true
similarly
if i have
the blank symbol is the thing that goes
in in that cell um then that variable
gets turned on i hope you can see it
maybe it's a little bit small on your
screen
um
the x i j blank
a variable is is true and similarly if
it's q seven here the x i j q seven
variable is true
okay so that that's the way we're going
to be encoding
the
contents of these cells
using these indicator variables
and now
we have to start
making some boolean logic to make sure
that those variables
reasonably represent
the cell con you know contents of these
cells so for example what would be the
first thing that comes to your mind
well we better not have
two lights
going on in any one of the cells because
then we have two symbols on that cells
and that's not allowed
each cell is going we want each cell to
have exactly one symbol and that
corresponds to each each each cell
having exactly one of its lights turned
on or equivalently each cell should have
exactly one of the variables be true
that's the very first part of the
formula is just going to say that so
let's let me show you how that what that
looks like
okay
so here we're talking about this free
cell
it says that there's exactly one light
on purcell
or in other words exactly one of the x
ij sigmas is true for each ij
um
so this is how i'm going to actually
express that using my boolean
formula
uh
i'm sort of color coding the different
parts of the formula which i'm writing
out to you here in english
so first i want to say there's a so in
every cell there's at least one light
that's on and there's almost one light
that's on
um so here's the green part this is
going to say at least one light is on so
i'm going to say that by taking
all of the very all of the symbols
that can appear in that cell
and and take taking in an or over all of
those different associated variables
so it's either got the first symbol on
or the second symbol is there or the or
dot or the last symbol is there one of
those has got to be there
i'm going to write this using my big or
notation
so for sigma
appearing in this
set of possibilities
one of those variables has got to be on
at least
that's what this or big word tells you
now i want to make sure
that there's at most one
that's on so that there are not there's
one at least one on but there are not
two that are on
so i'm gonna
have an additional part of the formula
here which says and i hope you can read
this
a little small
um
if i have two
different
symbols sigma and tau
that are
configuration
uh possible configuration symbols where
sigma and tau are not equal so that's
i'm reading it out to you if you can't
if it's too small for your screen
then i'm going to say it's not possible
so i have the negation
of x i j sigma and x i j tau so
saying in another way
it's not the case
that
that cell contains both sigma and tau
for any two symbols sigma and tau as
long as they're different
i'm going to take these two formulas and
add them together
and this tells me in the cell ij
is exactly one of the variables is true
exactly one of the lights is on and
that's going to represent which symbol
goes into that cell
and then i want to take the and over all
possible cells
to make sure that i'm going to now apply
that everywhere
and so i now i do an and
for i and j ranging between 1 and n to
the k to apply this logic throughout the
picture
yes sigma union asking sigma union q
contains the input output yes
this is not a sigma this is a gamma
gamma is the tape alphabet this is any
symbol including an input symbol um
from sigma
is going to be in in gamma so this is
any any symbol that can appear on the
tape
um okay and that's
this
this expression here that is the
expression feasible cell
okay
so here's a little check-in for you but
maybe before we jump into the check and
let's just make sure
maybe better to take some questions
and then we can ask a check-in
for you
you understand i mean if you're not
getting this
you should you should try to uh
try to figure out how to get it because
this is really just
the foundation it it only gets more it's
not it's not a very complicated proof
once you sort of get the idea what's
going on but if you're not getting this
part you won't be able to get the rest
okay i have no idea what
what that means but i'll read it out to
you guys this looks like a one-hot
tensor encoding same from common same
form commonly used in ml
okay
um
it's just an indicator i would just call
them indicator variables
um
why is it sigma union q
for the big and here
sigma union q
you mean gamma union q
this is wrong
okay
now i understand why everybody's upset
this should be a gamma not a sigma
uh there's a booboo
sorry about that
i don't know if i can fix that without
wrecking the whole slide but so i'm not
going to even try this symbol here
should be gamma not sigma
it's a typo
thanks for catching that
um
yes
so the question is
um
okay so
uh
feasible
is just trying to make sure that the
encoding
represents
setting a bunch of symbols into the
tableau
not so each cell is going to have one
symbol
exactly not two not zero
um so that's what pieces so if you've
satisfied if you set the variables to
satisfy feasible
then there's going to be one symbol on
in each
one in one symbol in each of those cells
um
now another question this is not a cnf
no this is not a cnf that's the second
half of the
that's going to be if we
hope we don't run out of time but i have
a way of converting general sat formulas
to cnfs um
and preserving satisfiability so we're
gonna do that reduction afterward
okay
let's let's
is it a little check to see if you
understand uh at some some level what's
going on
how many variables
does this formula actually have
is it order n order n square
enter the k
remember this
k is the running time of the machine
uh or n to the 2k
what do you think
so i i i mean for how many variables i
mean that in all of
uh
m sub m
yeah how many variables do we have all
together
in this formula if that's what the
question is
and here though here are the variables
so describing them here x i j sigma
okay i'm going to close this
so pick something
all right ending polling
one two three
okay
yeah so
um
okay so that's a good question um
so first of all the the correct answer
is in fact d it's order n to the 2k
um
now uh
i'm getting some questions about what
about the size of gamma and q
well those are going to be fixed
they depend only on the machine
but they don't depend on
n
so thinking about it in term
functionally in terms of n
that's going to be
a constant
multiplier um and so it's going to be
absorbed within the um the big o
uh so that's why we have uh you know
these are constant relative to n these
are fixed
um
they're not into the k possible symbols
there's a fixed number of symbols
depends only on the machine
so looking at a particular machine and
what happens when you look at large
inputs
so why is it d and not c
well don't forget how big is this table
um
this is n to the k by n to the k
so there are n's n to the 2k cell into
the k quantity squared or enter the 2k
cells here
um
and so there's a collection of variables
for each cell some fixed number
variables for each cell so that's why
it's order n to the 2k
good okay so let's uh
let's move on
i think we're actually oh no
um okay so we have one more
slide and i think then we have a break
after
uh so now let's next
uh talk about constructing
um
two more pieces of the
fisa bmw formula so we already got fisa
face of cell done
let's look at
fee sub start and fee sub except
and fistart
is going to tell us
that the start configuration has exactly
these
symbols
and
the accept
tells us
that the
bottom
configuration contains an accepting
state somewhere
so how we're going to write that down
well first of all i'm going to write
these down just cell by cell
so first of all fee start is going to
say
the cell 1 1
contains the q 0. i mean i know what the
start configuration
is it should be
because you know i
you know thinking of me or think you
know us as the reduction
the reduction is given m it's given w so
it knows what the start state is it
knows what the symbols of w
are
so it can it knows what that start
configuration is it's just q zero
followed by the n symbols of w followed
by blanks
so
it wants it wants the very first
um
cell in the in the left-hand corner here
to be a q0 the start state of the
machine which it knows so it's going to
say
x sub 1 1 q 0 that has to be turned on
so it's going to be and a bunch of a
bunch of variables here
and in order to satisfy fee sub start
all of those variables have to be set to
true
so that means
we have to have a q0 in that cell so now
we're going to do the next the next cell
here
the one two the next cell of the uh uh
start configuration so
fee start is going to have x12
so that's the next place contains w1
and so on
x13 contains w2
all the way
up to wn and then there's going to be a
bunch of additional
um
uh
parts which say that the
that we have blanks in the rest just
spelling out exactly all of the symbols
in that top row
because that's what the fiestart
um
uh
formula or sub formula of the of the
overall formula we're making looks like
okay
now let's take a look at fee accept
if you accept
because i'm just looking for
cue accept to appear somewhere
in that bottom row i'm going to do that
in terms of an or
so here is the variables now notice have
n to the k
because it's the last row in the table
so rho n to the k
here
and then i'm going to vary j from 1 to n
to the k so j the column number is going
to range from 1 to n to the k
and i'm looking for that q except so x
enter the kj which is where j is varying
and q accept
one of those has to be true
one of those has to be turned on and so
that's why it's a it's a big war
and that's my um
uh fee accept
peace okay
and now we'll take a little break and
feel free to ask me some more questions
um let me just start the our clock
and go grab yourself
some coffee or
ask me some questions happy to answer
them
why don't we check that q accept only
appears once
is it impossible for q except to appear
twice that's a great question
um
so that would definitely be a broken
configuration
if that happened because a configuration
can ha can have must have exactly one
state symbol appearing
the way we're going to enforce that is
is with the fee move
uh
part of the formula which we haven't
seen yet so p move is going to guarantee
that the machine is acting correctly so
that all of the rows of the tableau are
all legal configurations and they all
legally follow from the previous
so that really in a sense the hard heavy
lifting is coming in fee move
but it's really not that bad
um
somebody says out of curiosity how close
is this intuition proof to the actual
proof
this is the actual proof there's no i'm
not i'm not hiding anything
i mean you know we're being a little uh
loose here but you can turn this
this is this
not cutting any corners here this is
exactly how the proof goes um
and so uh
not not uh you're getting you're getting
the real deal here
somebody wanted to see the previous
slide so here we are whoops
is there something you want to ask
um
okay so fee cell says there's exactly
one symbol per cell
and the variables are set in a way in
terms of thinking of them as indicator
variables there's exactly one variable
set to true in each cell
so it's exactly one symbol per cell
that's what p cell the f cell tells you
what you know if you don't have that
then you have a mess
so you've got to start with that
and then with the other other things are
going to be additional conditions which
when satisfied going to enforce the rest
of the properties that we want
why would the proof fail if we
n to the k with 2 to the n to the k
so okay
i i presume you know
where does would this use the polynomial
running time of the machine uh of the of
m the nondeterministic machine
i mean if you had a an enormous tab we
have to show ultimately that this
reduction is a polynomial time reduction
and that's going to depend on how big
the tableau is because that's going to
tell us how big the formula we're
producing is fees of mw
if e sub mw is exponentially big we
don't have a prayer of being able to
output that formula in polynomial time
if there were
less than into the k steps do we repeat
the last configuration yeah that's what
i said if we have if the machine ends
early the last configuration just stays
there so we're going to
modify the definition of the machine
slightly so that you know the um so it
just stays
yeah
um
okay
um
yeah let me not take the other there's a
bunch of other questions some of them a
little on the technical side
um
let me uh maybe i'll try to address them
as they come along if it if it turns out
to work to do that
okay so uh the word the break is over
um
why don't we uh con is it possibly that
the encoding configuration will not fit
in
into the k
no no
so the question is is there a
possibility that the encoding of the
configuration won't fit into the k if
the machine runs for enter the k steps
the the configuration has to fit with an
end to the k because it can't use
anything more
within into the k steps to think about
it but no the ques the answer is there's
the configurations
if the machine runs time into the k
that whole um tableau is big enough to
write down the entire computation
history
all right so let's continue
fees of move
um
this is in a sense the part which is
going to tell us that
we started right
we ended right
um
fee cell says every every cell contains
one symbol and
now we have to say that the whole
interior is correct how are we going to
do that so these these are the parts
we've already done
and the way i'm going to describe that
is in terms of these kind of little
windows i'm calling neighborhoods
so
imagine here we have a two by three
rectangle
which i'm going to call a two by three
neighborhood
and
what i'm going to argue but i'm not
going to prove uh here i'm just going to
really state it but it's it's really
just a sort of
more or less obvious fact uh but the
proof the
book has the formal proof
that if any every one of these here is
legitimate is legal according to the
rules of the machine if every single
imagine
you know you have these um oops let me
put myself back on here so you can see
me
um if you have um
if you have here
every
um
two by three
window
you can take this as a window and you
slide that over the entire picture of
the tableau
and everything here looks okay as far as
the running of the machine so i'll say
what that means in a second
but if if everything looks locally fine
everywhere
then the whole tableau has to be
a valid tableau
in terms of the rules of m
um
maybe it's easier if i if i describe
what i mean by these being legal
um
so
these neighborhoods
um these two by three neighborhoods are
legal if they're consistent with m's
transition function so i'm going to
describe rather than i mean to do this
formally i would have to go through
kind of a process that we went like what
we did when we went through uh the
construction for the post correspondence
problem and see if the machine moves
left this thing's happens every move is
right that's i think that's
it's not really necessary you can kind
of get the idea very clearly by doing it
a little bit at a higher level um
so let's look at what i mean by a legal
neighborhood so this illegal
neighborhood is a setting of the values
the six values of this 2x3 neighborhood
in a way
which
doesn't violate m's rules
so for example
if m
when it's in state q7 reading a b
goes into state q3 and moves left
then this would be a legal neighborhood
because it shows
the head moving left
um the b becoming a c so reading a b i
should also say that it right converts
that b to a c
and and moves his head left into state
q3 so this would be a legal neighborhood
if that's the way
so being legal depends upon
um
it depends on the transition function of
the machine
so
given the transition function that's
going to tell you which of the legal
neighborhoods
so another legal neighborhood this would
always be a legal neighborhood is that
if nothing changes so that means the
head of the machine was somewhere else
and so
um
you know
whatever was on the tape in this step is
going to be the same stuff in the in
those places
one step later
um here's another possible legal
neighborhood um
is uh
if the head suddenly appears
you know on one of the on one of the
cells
either in the left or the right
that would correspond to the machine to
the machine moving its head from
somewhere off the nape off the
neighborhood into the neighborhood
you know in that step um so this could
be a legal neighborhood
provided the machine actually does move
its head left into a state q5 at some
point
under under some conditions
um
and here is another kind of a weird
illegal neighborhood if you have a b c
and then the a changes to a d
that could also be a legal neighborhood
if the machine
transition function allows
an a to get converted to a d when there
is some machine when there is some state
reading that a and that state also moves
its head left so it doesn't move into
this picture
so those are examples of legal
neighborhoods let me show you some
illegal neighborhoods
um just i'm doing this this is kind of a
proof by example now this is perhaps the
most intuitive part but i
claim that this is easy to turn this
into something airtight and formal
so this would be clearly illegal
if you're if you have
a piece of the
tape in the pre previous
step
where it's a b c and then suddenly the b
changes to a d the symbol on the tape
changes out of nowhere without having a
head nearby
uh to a different uh
to something else that could never
happen so that would be illegal
another thing would be illegal is if a
state appears from nowhere
that could never happen
um or if it just disappears that could
never happen
and here's another here's an interesting
one
if a state becomes two states
um don't forget the machine is
non-deterministic so the machine in
principle could move its head left
on one branch and move its head right on
a different branch but those would have
to be in different tableaus they can't
be in the same tableau
because that doesn't correspond to any
of the threads of the computation those
are multiple threads
um
and i say this because if you think
about
my claim which is going to put down over
here that if every
2x3 neighborhood is legal then the
tableau overall corresponds to a
computation history
this illustrates why it's not enough to
have a two by two two by two
neighborhood where you really need the
two by three
um
because if this was a two by two
neighborhood if you just look at these
four
this left most uh two by two
that could be
um
a legal neighborhood
if it was a two by two
if the rules of the machine allowed for
that and the right
four box
right four cells could also be a legal
neighborhood
so you could have something that looks
okay from the perspective of two by two
neighborhoods but
globally in terms of the overall tableau
is completely nonsensical because it has
multiple heads
um
but if you have a three two by three
neighborhood it's big enough to
prevent this situation from occurring
and
then you know you can check the details
uh and i think it's very plausible that
it guarantees
that the overall tableau is is is
legitimate if all of the two by three
neighborhoods are legal okay and so
that's what we're going to turn into
a um
a boolean expression
we're going to say for each cell
that the set
for each neighborhood so here's a
neighborhood at the iga location that's
i'm calling this sort of this position
here sort of the home location for that
um neighborhood
for each um
for each neighborhood
uh
it has to be set to one of the legal uh
possibilities
and there's again only a fixed number of
those because there's a fixed number of
possible symbols that can appear in
those cells
um so this is that fixed number to the
sixth power at most
and i'm going to say that
um
you know the cell in the upper left
which would be this one
is an r
and this one and this one here is an s
and this one is a t
and this and this one is a v if you just
trace down what the indices are telling
you
it says that
that piece of the tape that piece of the
tableau here is set
according to
one of the possible legal settings
and i'm just going to or over all of
those possible
fixed number of legal settings
and then i take a an and
over all possible tape cells over all
possible neighborhoods
and so that's going to be my fee move
and that's that's it
okay let's see can i explain again the
third example of illegal
so this one over here i presume is i'm
being asked about
well you know if the machine is in a
state q7
you know reading a c
you know the head has to move either
left or right so that at the next
you know the next um configuration
there's got to be a state symbol
appearing either in this cell
or in this cell
and here the tape you know the the the
the head has basically just vanished
with nowhere to you know
it's it's gone
that could not happen in the in the
you know
according to the rules of the machine
the way we talk about turing machines so
that's not possible so this would be an
illegal
um
a neighborhood
you want to prevent any of the ill bad
stuff from happening anywhere in here
it's only good stuff can be happening
locally and that guarantees the overall
picture is okay
um
do we have to check that the head
doesn't leave the tabo from the left
most or right yeah there are some little
details here like that so the question
is you know have to make sure that that
the
yeah you probably need to mark i think
the book probably does this correctly
you may have to mark the left and right
ends to make sure that i mean the right
end can is not a problem because the the
the
the machine can never go um
off the right end
and if you design the machine so that it
never moves its head off the left end
either which you can do then you
wouldn't have to worry about that
possibility but yeah otherwise you would
have to put some sort of delimiter here
to uh to enforce the mach the head not
moving off the left end so there are
some details like that too um
there will be two heads in the same row
no this can i don't know what you
somebody says there will be two heads in
the same row
please elaborate because
this is designed not to allow two heads
in the same row
could i go over the or for legal again
okay the or
so the the big or here
what i have in mind is i i take there's
gonna be first of all i look at the
machine and i look at the transition
function
and based on that
i write down
the list of all the legal two by three
neighborhoods so all the settings which
correspond to legal two way two by three
neighborhoods there's gonna be some
fixed number of those
you know
a hundred
there's a hundred possible legal
neighborhoods
of which you know i've written down here
four
but maybe there's some some number say a
hundred so now there's going to be an
ore
over those hundred different
possibilities it's either going to be
this legal neighborhood or some other
legal neighborhood or some other legal
neighborhood and for each one of those
legal neighborhoods
i'm going to say well
the variables are set according to that
legal neighborhood
or
the the variables are set according to
the next legal neighborhood or the
variables are set according to the next
legal neighborhood and do that 100 times
one of those has got to end up it's an
ore so one of them has to work
otherwise the formula fails and will be
false
because you're going to now end that
over all of the neighborhoods in the
picture
is it possible to have a head on the far
left of the configuration and one on the
far right
you mean a head over here
and a head over there i mean
how did the head get there can't happen
um
you know the head the head has to come
from a head above it um
if you're going to be worrying about the
you know details of the boundaries here
you know
all that's fixable so let's not
you know um
lose sight of the main idea i mean if
you understand the main idea you can fix
little details
so i want to make sure you understand
the main idea what's happening
okay so let's finish up this proof
um
so in summary
um we gave a reduction
from a to sat this is what we
needed
it was in those four pieces
and you really just need to argue that
that
formula we're building is not too big
it's and it's going to be basically the
size of the tableau if you look at what
we constructed
the number of variables is roughly the
size of the tableau
and the amount of logic that we're
putting into the formula is also going
to be a fixed amount of logic
independent of n
for each of the variables
in that tableau
and now somebody asked me about like
this how big the indices are
um
you know the indices
for the you know the x i value the inj
values um
technically they're going to be numbers
between 1 and n to the k
so you're going to have to write those
down and so that's going to be a slight
additional logarithmic cost um to write
those things down but it's not really
that interesting a point
um
and so
the overall f is going to be computable
in polynomial time because the output is
not very big and it's also not
complicated to write the output down
so that's the end of the that's the end
of the proof
um
i can take a couple of questions
we why can't we just check that the
whole this is a good question why can't
we just check that the whole row is
legal
um
you know you can check that you can
check that a row actually is a is a
configuration but you to check that the
row follows from the previous row
um
you know ultimately
the operation of a turing machine is is
a local
thing i mean hey
you know the way the the the way
it moves from one configuration to the
next depends locally on how the those
you know where the head is
and so really that's just another way of
the way i'm saying it is just really
checking the whole configuration but
just doing it locally
i don't know if that's satisfying to you
um
okay uh
why don't i move on because i just want
to make sure we have enough time to get
to the very last part which is a little
bit i'm afraid a little technical um so
we're going to kind of shift gears now
and talk about reducing sat to three set
and
um
let's let's see how it goes um i i don't
always have the most success with with
presenting this uh this little piece
because it's slightly a technical
argument but
um if you don't get it don't worry just
you have to accept that it's true um but
i'd like to show it to you just to makes
the whole presentation uh
you know complete in that sense okay um
so i'm going to give a reduction that
maps
general formulas to three cnf formulas
so that's how i map sat
to
if you remember threesat is
satisfiability but for
three cnfs so it's conjunctive normal
form you're in the form of those clauses
which are anded together and each clause
is an or of a bunch of literals which
are variables or negated variables
so i want to convert phi to phi prime
um which is a three cnf formula but
preserve the satisfiability
feed prime is not going to be logically
equivalent to fee
because i you know i could do that too i
can convert any formula to a logically
equivalent cnf formula maybe not even a
three second of it but yeah you won't be
able to get a 3c enough but you can get
a c and f
but um it might be exponentially larger
and that's not good enough i have to do
the reduction in polynomial time so i
can't generate a much larger formula
that's exponentially larger and so i'm
going to
do that by adding additional variables
so it won't be logically equivalent
because the new formula is going to have
additional variables in it
okay i'm going to kind of do it by
example
and let's see how that goes
so his fee
which is not
in
3c and f it's not even in cnf
because it's got you know
uh orrs of ands appearing which are not
allowed to happen in a cnf
okay so
how we're going to convert that
into a 3cnf formula preserving the
satisfiability and just working it
through with this example
i hope at least give you some idea of
how you of how to do the conversion in
general
so first of all i'm going to represent
this formula as a tree
using its natural tree structure
so you understand so a and b becomes a
and b written as a tree and then i take
or that with c
so i get the tree structure here in sort
of the natural way
and i'm going to label all of these
intermediate nodes which are associated
now with
operations
and
um i'm assuming also that the formula is
fully parenthesized
so that each operation i'm only thinking
about is applying just a two it's a
binary operation
um and let's let's ignore negations for
the minute because negations you can
always push those through down to the
leaves but
it's just going to make it too
complicated
so negations turn out not to be a
problem
so there's only going to be negations at
the level of the
inputs
not at the not negation operations in
the middle
okay so we have this tree structure here
and now i'm going to use these two
logical facts
you know
and i don't know if
you know you've probably all seen hands
and ors i hope otherwise it's going to
be really tough uh but there's also
other logical operators such as the
implication operator
where you have a implies b
thought of as a logical operator
operation
um and so that this is only this
requires that if a is true then b is
true
um
however if a is false
b can be anything
uh and similarly if b is true a can be
anything
um
the only thing that's prohibited is that
if a is true and b is false
that's the only thing that's uh
would be invalid
and so if you think about it that's
going to be equivalent to saying that
either a is false or b is true
one of those has to be
and that's going to be logically
equivalent to saying that a implies b
another logical equivalence maybe is
more familiar to you is just simply de
morgan's laws the mortgage law which
says that if you have the
a not of a and b that's uh equivalent to
saying
uh the not of a or the knot of b
okay i'm going to make use of both of
these
um
now
now here i want to i ran out of room on
the slide so i'm going to take myself
out of the picture here for for a minute
um
uh
i had no place else to put this
so here we have if you're going to think
of the and
in terms of its truth table
so here's a and b in terms of a and b
so if one and one is one
but all other settings of a and b
uh yield zero for the and
i'm going to represent those um
if you imagine a and b is going to be
called c
i'm going to represent this information
with uh four
um small formulas
which taken together you and them
together kind of force c to have the
correct behavior associated with a and b
okay um
so uh
so if a and b are both one and c is one
if a is zero
and b is one
um then
that so then it forces c to be zero
um
and
similarly you know every other setting
besides a and b being
being true
uh
for c to be false which is what you want
when you have and
so i'm gonna write this expression here
down with z1 being in the place of c
by just taking those four
uh expressions and ending them together
so this is exactly those same four
expressions written out linearly
now i want to do the same thing
for z2 but now that's written in terms
of an or
so it's a slightly different truth table
here up in this corner
uh
so now if either one is a one we get a
one result
and so
now
you know if a a and b are true you get
uh c is true
however if a is true and b is false that
still implies c is true
um so
i'm going to write down
uh those rules for specifying how
uh
z2
must be set
and each one of these things is going to
get converted into clauses
three clauses with three literals using
these uh using these um using these
rules over here
so
i'm going to do that for each zi
and lastly to make sure the whole thing
is satisfied which means there's an
output of one here i'm going to have one
clause associated
which says that z4 the output
is a one
now i can convert all of those
when i have a and b imply c that's
logically equivalent to not a or not b
or or c
and the way you can see that is really
by repeated app by application of these
uh rules here
running a little low on time
so
maybe you'll just have to check this
offline
but
quickly
a and b implies c using the first
equivalence is the not of this part or c
and then i can use the morgan to convert
that uh
knot of an and to an or of the knots
and then
and then
i can remove the parenthesis because
uh or is associative
and so i get a
uh
a clause which is what i need so each
one of these guys is really equivalent
to a clause and so i just get a bunch of
clauses and actually technically this
needs to be three um
copy of
three things here should it should be z4
or z4 or z4
which is a lot
um
so checking numbers so i realize my
checking is broken because i only
realized that last point just now as i
was talking so uh
the the actual
uh value that you get in terms of oh no
the number of clauses is correct
no i i i take it back this is fine
so if you understood what i was saying
hopefully you can see how big the
formula fif
fee prime
is in terms of the number of operations
and fee
so let's let's see how many people get
that
i i i acknowledge this maybe a little on
the technical side
okay i'm gonna close it
close it
down please enter your value
okay
yeah the correct answer is 4k plus one
um
because each one of these
operations
is going to end up being a row in this
picture
it's going each operation is going to
have a variable associated to it it's
going to become a row in this picture
and so then and each row is going to
have
four
um clauses which define
um
you know uh
what you need set what you need in order
to force the that that that variable to
have the right value corresponding to
that operation
okay and so then you need and you need
one extra clause here
uh for uh saying that the the this whole
thing evaluates to true
um
okay so that's all i wanted to uh
do today um we proved those two main
theorems
and now we know that there are
np-complete problems and all of the
other
problems that we can get from
by reductions from these problems um
are also going to be np-complete as long
as they're an np
okay so um that's that's it
feel free to
put some questions into the chat
or
move on to whatever else you're going to
be doing next okay so a good question
here is why is fee prime not logically
equivalent with this construction can't
be logically equivalent has
logically equivalent means that it gives
you exactly the same function as you if
you set the variables in the same way
you get the same result coming out
well
v prime has more variables than phi does
so it wouldn't even make sense to talk
about logical equivalence because there
are two functions on different numbers
of variables so in that sense it doesn't
really make sense
you know what you could say is that for
every setting of the
of the overlapping variables of the
variables that appear in both ph and v
prime so those are the original
variables of fee um there's going to
exist some setting of the new variables
which is going to make um
the uh
you know
yeah there's going to be there will
exist some setting of the new variables
which will make the the two formulas
agree but that's not the definition of
logic logical equivalence
okay so
why going back to the proof of status
the satisfiability proof and the legal
neighborhoods
could i go over why the number of legal
neighborhoods is polynomial
the number of legal neighborhoods is not
only polynomial it's constant
it depends only on the machine it does
not depend on n
so
because each cell
can have at most some fixed number of
you know can have the number of tape
symbols plus the number of state symbols
that's
you know that depends on the machine
only
so
uh now we have six six tape cells for
the six cells in a two by three
neighborhood so you're going to have
that number to the sixth power but it's
still it's a constant to the sixth power
still a constant doesn't depend on n
so it's not a question of even being
polynomial um it's it's a it's a
constant value it's a constant
multiplier uh if you want to think about
it in terms of the um
the size of the formula that's going to
result don't forget you know we're
trying to make a
formula
um which is
uh well the reduction has to be
polynomial
um it's a polynomial time reduction so
that means that as n increases the time
to calculate the reduction increases as
a polynomial
but
we're fixing m so m does not
change so therefore anything that
depends on m only is just going to be a
constant um impact on the formula it's
not going to be it doesn't depend on it
okay everybody
bye-bye see you
you